-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since the NFL season has
officially kicked off today,
I sent out the #FootballRaps.
And I asked you guys to send us
your funny raps about football.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
We do it every week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite football raps
from you guys with a little help
from the Roots.
This first one is
from @mattyboh.
-Matty Boh.
-He says...
♪ -I saw Lamar Jackson, ooh ♪
♪ He is for real ♪
♪ MVP awards will multiply ♪
♪ Always makes the Browns
and Steelers cry ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Lamar Jackson. Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
That's good. This next one
is from @timmiller95.
He says...
♪ -You probably think the Jets
are better now, better now ♪
♪ But they can't even ever beat
the Browns, beat the Browns ♪
♪ You know they're always gonna
let you down, let you down ♪
♪ They can't win anything,
can't win anything ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, hey. Hey!
-Rude.
-Hey, wait a sec.
-That's rude.
-Yeah.
This next one is
from @trillocarl.
And he says...
♪ -I'm gonna take my team
to the Super Bowl ♪
♪ I'm gonna try to kick
a ton of field goals ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Simple.
-Come on, simple.
-It's good stuff.
-To the point.
-Lil Nas X.
-Kids love it.
-Yeah, the kids love it.
This one is from
@jakewilliamsart.
He says...
♪ -I'm Tom Brady,
yes, I'm the real Brady ♪
♪ All you other Tom Bradys
are just out tailgatin' ♪
♪ They say you're getting old,
Tom ♪
♪ Please get up, please get up,
please get up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Yo!
That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know how Tariq just
makes it all sound cool, yeah.
This one's from @bigbillywilly.
He says...
♪ -Stadium prices suck
on a Sunday ♪
♪ So expensive ♪
♪ I don't think I'm hun-gray ♪
♪ Price is really tough
on a Sunday ♪
♪ Hot dog cost as much
as a Hyundai ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-We got to hire this guy.
That's a good one.
-We got to hire Big Billy Willy.
"Hot dog costs as much
as a Hyundai."
-That's the one. That's the one.
-That is the line of the year
maybe, from @bigbillywilly.
He gets a follow on that one.
-Say that one like
Little Caesar's.
-Big Billy Willy.
[ Laughter ]
-Pizza pizza.
-This one is
from @reneejordan78.
She says...
♪♪
♪ -Guess who's throwin'
a hail tonight ♪
♪ Guess who's throwin'
♪ Gronk gon' catch my hail
tonight ♪
-Yeah. A little Kanye.
[ Applause ]
This one is from @kyledice23.
He says...
♪ -Shawty had them
spiky bottom cleats ♪
♪ Cheerleader skirt ♪
♪ The fans in the crowd
had no shirts ♪
♪ 60-yard throw ♪
♪ Next thing you know ♪
♪ Shawty went pro, pro,
pro, pro ♪
♪ P-P-P-P-P-Pro ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
-P-P-P-P-Pro!
-This last one is
from @minister -- No.
It's mister, sorry.
I thought it was
Minister Dorngal.
-Minister Dorngal?
-Minister Dorngal sounds like
a show on the BBC.
-Yeah, a kids' show.
-No, it's PBS,
like "Downton Abbey."
[ British accent ] Welcome back.
Masterpiece Theater presents
"Minister Dorngal."
[ Laughter ]
-The church is on fire.
-How dare you, sir?!
[ Slap ]
[ Normal voice ]
@misterdorngal58.
He says...
♪ -I got my Falcons
down in Georgia ♪
♪ -Yeah, that's it ♪
♪ -I got my Rams in California ♪
♪ -Yeah, they're fit ♪
♪ -I got my Seahawks
to the north, yeah ♪
♪ -Seattle sitch ♪
♪ -I saw my Lions down by 10 ♪
♪ -Then I quit ♪
-Oh! There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.